a rumored Affair a violent assault and
some serious allegations did Netflix's
new Marilyn Monroe feature go too far
Netflix is blonde which is based on
Joyce Carol oates's novel of the same
name and starzana de armas as Marilyn
Monroe has been creating a lot of
controversy despite being a work of
fiction blonde is shocked audiences
because it draws inspiration from one of
Hollywood's most iconic figures and as
it received an NC-17 rating meaning that
it contains several shocking scenes the
fictionalized account of Monroe's life
explores a possible trauma failures
successes and intense pressure that some
like a hot star might have faced
throughout her life viewers are given an
imagine behind the scenes look at what
the world's most famous stars face
examining the human being inside the
Gilded veneer of the myth while it's
true that some people want nothing more
than to be famous others come to Rue
such a bright Spotlight since blonde
draws inspiration from the life of a
historical figure several other
real-life people associated with the
star also feature in the fictional
account however not everyone is shown in
a flattering light discussing the film's
NC 17 rating the armas told Empire it's
a film that is supposed to create
controversy and discomfort and it's
supposed to make you think about what
happened and what is still happening
it's revolutionary and I think it's so
brave the actor also pointed out that
although blonde is rated nc17 she
doesn't consider the movie's content
particularly gratuitous saying despite
the NC-17 rating I never felt that there
was anything exploitative this movie is
meant to be an experience to move along
with their feelings what she's going
through and that unfortunately takes
What It Takes however it quickly became
clear that blonde features one
especially gut-wrenching scene that's
harrowing and deeply uncomfortable for
both viewers and history aficionados
alike according to the Daily Beast this
particular scene in blonde focuses on
Marilyn Monroe and John F Kennedy played
by Casper Phillipson the moment begins
with Monroe being picked up by Secret
Service agents from an airplane in New
York City the actress is then dragged
through a hotel and presented to Kennedy
and that's when the story becomes
shocking I'm not a child
you don't have to worry about me
and Netflix's fictional accounts
Kennedy's sexually assaults Monroe
multiple times which is understandably
difficult for audiences to watch in the
movie when Monroe wakes up she is bloody
and bruised however presidential
historians will likely take exception
with how the alleged relationship
between the president and the film star
has been presented obviously it has long
been rumored that the real-life Kennedy
and Monroe had some kind of relationship
with one another for instance Frank
Sinatra's friend Antonio pedisano opened
up to people about the possible
connection alleging it was obviously a
sexual thing and I would expect that
there were feelings on her side just
taking a look at the footage of her
singing her happy birthday that speaks
for itself she respected him she admired
him she loved what he was doing with the
country and then to have a physical
relationship with them she found him
attractive and vice versa however not
everyone agrees that Monroe and Kennedy
were actually engaged in any sort of
illicit Affair as a result many
historians will likely find fault when
Netflix is blonde and the devastating
suggestion that Monroe was assaulted by
the president however it's crucial to
remember that the new film is based upon
level and not a biography whether or not
Kennedy and Monroe were romantically
linked in real life long continues to
shock viewers due to its explicit
content if you or anyone you know has
been a victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abuse and
incest National Network website or
contact Reigns National helpline at
1-800-656-04673
[Music]